it's seven o'clock this is sky news
breakfast our top stories this morning
mixed messaging covered confusion ahead
of new year's eve parties tonight as
leading scientists warn of great concern
over a lack of available tests
venues that are normally sold out two
weeks ago are half sold out and we're
screaming in pain
reasons to be cheerful labour set out
their vision for a new britain in 2022
as boris johnson casts a positive
outlook on the year ahead
we can say one thing with certainty
our position this december the 31st is
incomparably better than last year
they must be brought to justice galen
maxwell's victims so attention should
now turn to her and jeffrey epstein's
accomplices
i'm in new york where glenn maxwell is
being held inside the brooklyn
metropolitan detention center she'll
remain here until she's sentenced next
year
[Music]
a warning for the white house vladimir
putin tells joe biden not to impose new
sanctions over ukraine
the world is full of beauty
and it's up to you to capture it
sky news speaks to the stars of the new
film celebrating the life of 19th
century artist louis wayne and his
feline friends
at the weather exceptionally mild for
new year's eve but unsettled in the
north with rain mostly fine for england
and wales and at the quarter 2 we'll
take a look at the morning's papers
today i'll be joined by the editor of
spike magazine tom slater and the author
nikki hodgson
[Music]
hello there very good morning i'm
jonathan samuels the government is being
accused of mixed messaging ahead of new
year's eve celebrations tonight despite
not bringing in further restrictions
ahead of one of the biggest nights of
the year boris johnson has warned
revellers in england to be cautious as
they head out and take a test if they
can but there's still a shortage of
lateral flow and pcr tests with calls
for health staff to be given priority
access meanwhile health leaders have
warned that up to 40 percent of vaccine
appointments at the moment are no shows
skies sergeant chowdhury reports
with just a day before the new year
comes in it's unusual for alex proud to
have time for a television interview
but there's not much else to do
look there's hardly any staff needed
we're not sold out and that story is the
same across the country you know venues
that are normally sold out two weeks ago
a half sold out and we're screaming in
pain alex says confusion over what is
and isn't safe is driving business away
from his club and country this is one of
the few things britain really is famous
for it's nighttime industry whether it's
manchester liverpool edinburgh glasgow
or london this is what we're famous for
and we destroy this you're taking half
the reason people come to britain
unlike in other parts of the uk in
england the prime minister has given big
indoor new year celebrations the go
ahead
in london there will be no fireworks to
thunder through the city
but there will be one sound reminiscent
of a time without kovid the last time we
heard big ben ring in a new year well
that was long before the pandemic
this time it'll chime in yet another
uncertain year ahead when there are
rising coved cases and mounting concern
about people mixing over new year's
celebrations when there's a shortage of
covered tests
scientists say crowded indoor parties
are the perfect conditions for spreading
kovid i find it odd really that we're in
a situation where we're worried enough
about the wave of omicron to build um
new nightingale capacity um but we're
we're not worried enough to suggest to
people that
new year's eve parties are not a good
idea as england parties the government
hopes the booster shot will be enough to
keep us all safe
it says the target to offer one to every
eligible adult has been reached though
of course that doesn't mean every person
given the chance
necessarily took it
around 7 in 10 adults have now had a
booster but many more will need to as
the uk seeks to beat kovid in the year
ahead
sadia chowdhury sky news in westminster
well even though there aren't any
restrictions in place in england for new
year's eve tonight that's not the case
in the other nations of the uk pub
landlords in wales and scotland look set
to have their profits slashed as regular
punters travel over the border to bring
in 2022 free of restrictions and at ten
past nine we'll speak to some of those
pub landlords on england's borders with
wales and scotland who are braced for
what will be very different new year's
eve this evening and as the nation
prepares to see in 2022 political
leaders have been setting out their
hopes and visions for the new year boris
johnson said in the fight against kovid
19 the uk is in an incomparably better
position than 12 months ago whilst the
labour leader sakia stamina said he
believes the best still lies ahead for
britain
happy new year 2022 is almost upon us
and whatever the challenges that fate
continues to throw in our way and
whatever the anxieties we may have about
the weeks and months ahead particularly
about omicron and the growing numbers in
hospitals
we can say one thing with certainty
our position this december the 31st is
incomparably better than last year
given the last two years our country's
been through
it would be all too easy
to lose heart
but like you
i believe in britain
i believe the best still lies ahead for
britain
that if we make the right choices
together
we can seize the future and make it work
for every family in every part of
britain
that must be the true legacy of our
sacrifices and pain of the last two
years in the pandemic
well we can take a look now at the
latest covert data there were 189 213
new cases of kovid 19 reported in the uk
over 24 hours 146 604 of those new cases
were in england another 332 deaths have
been reported within 28 days of a
positive test that brings the total
number of deaths in the uk to 148
400 421 the high number of deaths
reported on thursday does include a
backlog of hospital death data from the
nhs between the 24th and the 29th of
december
well as of wednesday there were 11 898
people in hospital in the uk with kovid
19 more than a thousand more than the
previous day and the highest total since
early march however this is still well
below the peak of more than 38 000 in
january and the number of people on
ventilators remain steady at 868.
32 607 people have received their first
dose of a vaccine with 43
766 getting their second that means that
nearly 47.4 million people have now
received their second dose onto the
boosters 435
293 new boosters or third jabs were
reported in the latest 24-hour period
more than 33 and a half million people
have now had one of those
well away from coronavirus they must be
brought to justice is the message from
the victims of glenn maxwell who have
spoken out of their relief for the
guilty verdicts of her trial in new york
maxwell was found guilty of five out of
six counts she faced including sex
trafficking a minor for the late
billionaire jeffrey epstein to abuse as
she awaits her sentencing attention has
now turned to blowing the whistle on
maxwell's and epstein's other
accomplices whose survivors believe were
involved in the scandal sky's us
correspondent martha calner reports now
from new york
gilan maxwell traveled on private planes
between mansions on sprawling estates
but inside these homes she and jeffrey
epstein orchestrated a sex trafficking
operation
teenagers from fractured families
singled out for sexual abuse and brought
here virginia's you frey says she was
trafficked around the world and forced
to have sex with famous men including
prince andrew claims he denies
rhino is just grateful because we
were told constantly you know
these people will never go to jail they
they're too powerful they're too rich
and
and we live in a new day and it just
goes to show that
you know
this is not the end this is just the
beginning
this former federal prosecutor believes
maxwell will spend the rest of her life
in prison unless she can cut a deal
is there any chance that glenn maxwell's
sentence could be commuted if she were
to blow the whistle for example on
co-conspirators
there certainly is a process where
individuals can cooperate after
conviction
and get you know credit for that
cooperation
in this case i haven't seen any
indication that that's going to happen
she would have to bring some incredibly
valuable information to the table
for the government to want to meet with
her
after the verdict was handed down gulen
maxwell was brought back here to the
brooklyn metropolitan detention center
where she spent the past 18 months of
her life i've just spoken to her
personal lawyer leah saffin who was
dropping off legal papers in the
building behind me she said she'd not
been allowed to see maxwell but repeated
to me allegations that she's been
subjected to what she called cruel and
unusual punishments inside here
annie farmer's testimony was key to
bringing down maxwell but it wasn't just
the women who took the stand in this
case whose lives were devastated
only four victims testified and they
were very brave to do so
but it's estimated that there may have
been
160 or more
victims of jeffrey epstein
and
a number of them may also have been
victims of ms maxwell
they were partners in crime two sexual
predators but survivors believed there
were more involved in this scheme for
whom justice is also long overdue
sky news new york
martha has the latest for us now from
new york
gillen maxwell faces a total maximum of
65 years in prison her lawyers and her
family are keen that that sentencing
process happens as soon as possible so
she can be moved away from this facility
to another elsewhere in the country
which they hope will be more comfortable
her family insist on her innocence
they're defiant and say that she's been
scapegoated for the crimes of geoffrey
epstein but this is not the end of the
story as far as the legal process goes
for gulen maxwell she still faces two
outstanding perjury charges it may be
though that federal prosecutors opt to
lay those to one side because they've
been so successful in this initial
prosecution and because it seems likely
that glenn maxwell will already spend
the rest of her life behind bars
ahmath kelner there now u.s president
joe biden has spoken to his russian
counterpart vladimir putin amid
continuing concerns over the build-up of
russian troops at the ukrainian border
it's the second time this month that the
two leaders have discussed the issue sky
security and defense editor debra haynes
joins me now so deborah uh the two men
having this phone conversation do we
know what was discussed
well it seems as though the the issues
that they went through were quite
similar to the conversation that they
had earlier in the month but the fact
that the two leaders are talking is
hugely significant at this time of
heightened crisis over ukraine and
concerns particularly in the united
states and the uk at the potential for a
possible russian invasion of further
invasion of ukraine in the new year now
specific details in terms of actual
negotiating points haven't emerged and
joe biden repeated the threats that the
united states has made that any further
military action by russia into ukraine
would be met with unprecedented
sanctions but president putin retorted
to this saying that any sanctions now or
later by the united states could lead to
a complete breakdown in relations
between the us and russia which would be
something that he said would be seen as
a huge mistake by future generations so
a sign there of the russian leader
setting his position
in response to any further american
action but the key message from the
united states is that any progress in
diplomacy has to happen at a time of
de-escalation and at the moment we're
just not seeing any sign of that around
ukraine where around a hundred thousand
russian troops
have been building
but on the russian side they have asked
very clearly that they want guarantees
that the united states and its nato
allies won't be posing a threat to its
borders they make the point that how
would the united states like it if
weapons from another country were put
close to its borders obviously the u.s
says that any actions around that area
by nato are purely defensive but that
doesn't wash with russia but this
dialogue was all about really setting
the scenes for some important diplomatic
moves that are going to be happening
early in the new year between the two
sides
yeah we'll see how things develop in
2022 deborah thank you very much
now with the surge in omicron cases
starting to translate to increased
hospitalizations pressure is mounting on
the health service once again but there
are fears that a shortage of covid 19
rapid tests is leaving the nhs hamstrung
with thousands of healthcare workers now
having to self-isolate joining me is the
chair of the british medical association
dr chand nag paul great to see you this
morning on this new year's eve
so just explain to me how much of an
issue
nhs staff absence is at the moment
and this is a significant problem
because when you have such
high levels of omicron in the community
nhs staff are also affected in fact in
the period before christmas we had seen
a 50 increase in staff absence due to
covet uh across the country now today
when the pub new figures are published i
think that will be even higher in london
in particular which is in a good example
of where the problem lies
is that we've seen up to about a three
times
increase in staff absence from
either
infection or isolation in some london
hospitals now that's you know creating
huge pressure on the system when we
already uh are short staffed at the
busiest time of the year
and to add to that problem we now have
the situation where many staff cannot
get their natural flow tests or a pcr
test which means that they can't return
to work because what they need to return
to work is to demonstrate a negative
lateral flow test on day six and seven
which was specially introduced so that
we could shorten the period of isolation
so this is creating enormous problems
for us
and for the workforce that remains
they're having to carry out the work of
their absent colleagues and that's
adding additional strain and stress but
patients are therefore going to suffer
as a result
yeah now the department of health says
that the nhs has its own dedicated
supply channel when it comes to getting
tests
is that not working
unfortunately we've had reports from
across the country of healthcare staff
who have not been able to access their
uh tests and results uh and as a result
uh you know they haven't been able to
provide the evidence that they are able
to return to work uh in some cases
there's been a delay where uh for
example they could have returned to work
on say yesterday but but because of the
lack of being able to have a test
they've had to uh um you know delay that
day by day and that just means that
you're for example in a gp practice
you're having to cancel an entire gp
clinic surgery or you're going to have
to cancel a whole session of taking of a
staff member who might be taking bloods
like a healthcare assistant having to
cancel her clinic or his clinic so you
know this is the sort of reality we're
having to face at the moment
yeah it's a real worry the health
secretary is saying that supplies will
be constrained for a fortnight due to
demand so it's not going to go away
immediately just while we've got you on
let me ask you about something else
that's in in the newspapers this morning
they had a head of nhs providers says
that they don't believe more curbs are
needed numbers are going up of
coronavirus cases but serious illness
amongst the elderly hasn't risen
significantly um that's cause for
optimism isn't it
i i think i mean we need to really watch
the data very carefully
what's concerning is that
we are seeing significant increases in
people in hospital
in fact we now last yesterday the number
of people admitted and also the number
of patients in hospital you know is at a
level as high as during the lockdown
earlier this year uh in spring uh in
sort of february march now that's a
pretty significant number and it's
increasing so whilst the proportion of
people who end up in hospital as a
result of omicron is is smaller we're
definitely seeing significant increases
and and the trouble is that those um
increases in hospitalization mean that
other patients and you know six million
people are on a waiting list at the
moment it's a record for the nhs uh 312
000 have been waiting more than 12
months it means that they can't then be
treated in hospital because their beds
are being occupied by other patients you
know 25 000 patients were admitted with
uh um covid uh in in a four week period
before christmas those are 25 000 beds
that could have been available for other
uh patients so
to interrupt that's 25 000 people
who are admitted hospital because of
covid or for other reasons and just
happen to have covered or get carried
right now okay that's a very good
question and in fact that's data that i
don't have and data that we really do
need to be
is important to be made available
because i absolutely agree we need to
differentiate between the two uh we
don't have that data
okay all right we will leave it there
and uh we wish you a happy new year dr
chan negpol thank you thank you very
much
and now murder investigation has been
launched after a 15 year old boy was
stabbed to death in a park in south
london police were called to ashburton
park in croydon just after seven o'clock
last night it's the 29th teenage killing
in the capital this year the highest
since 2008 guys melania vasilinovich is
in the newsroom for us just awful this
case what are the details really
horrible jonathan the police officers
gave the board first aid before the
emergency services the ambulance service
arrived but sadly he was pronounced dead
at 7 36 p.m now formal identification
has not yet taken place but the police
said that the boys family have been
notified and a postmortem will be held
in due course the police also said that
no one has yet been arrested for this
and as you say this is just the latest
in a string of teenage homicides in
london this year 29 with the youngest
victim of stabbing being just 14 years
old
this deadly toll equals the peak from
2008.
now the police say that they are
throwing all the resources that they
have behind investigating teenage
homicides and they also say that they
are not taking stabbings lightly they're
not being complacent about this but
every single time something like this
happens there's a heartbroken family
left behind and there's also a community
asking what could have been done to
prevent something like this from
happening
malaysia thank you
let's take a look at some of the other
stories making news this morning and a
state of emergency has been declared in
the u.s state of colorado after
wildfires burned hundreds of homes near
denver at least six people have been
injured with tens of thousands now told
to evacuate the blazes started on
thursday morning and have quickly spread
due to strong winds of up to 105 miles
an hour
now cove isolation can be unpleasant at
the best of times but one woman has
shared her ordeal of isolating in a
plane toilet marissa fatteo tested
positive for covid during her flight
from chicago to iceland and decided to
lock herself in the loo for five hours
to protect the other passengers she
captured her journey of confinement in
the tiny cubicle in a tick-tock video
that's been viewed more than three
million times
i started having a severe sore throat
and so i just took my rapid test and i
brought it into the bathroom and
within
what felt like two seconds there were
two lines there's like 150 people on
this flight
um and my biggest fear was giving it to
them
[Music]
research has uncovered a masonic
connection to why revelers around the
world link arms when they sing ol lang
syne at new year the study of robert
burns best love song links to the
practice to freemasonry where singing
with arms crossed and hands joined was a
parting ritual
in many lodges and i bet you still don't
know the words
thousands of people in england will be
flooding to the pubs and clubs later to
see out 2021 with no restrictions in
place but the situation in scotland and
wales of course isn't quite as jolly
with restrictions interrupting usual new
year celebrations well greg mulholland
is the campaign director at campaign for
pubs and he joins me now nice to see you
thanks for being with us tricky times
isn't it talk to me about tonight what
are pub managers saying about the
differing restrictions depending on
where you live
well it's incredibly frustrating for
republicans particularly of course
republicans who are
just on the scottish side of the
scotland england border or the welsh
side of the the england wales border
you have situations where in some cases
people's nearest pub is actually in the
other country
um but there's a huge temptation for
people in
scotland in wales to travel over the
border to have a new year without
restrictions and that's that's a further
blow actually for scottish and welsh
republicans on top of the the very
difficult december and that's a
difficult december for all republicans
in the uk so you know this was entirely
predictable
and it's something that that will happen
and i'm afraid that it hasn't really
been coordinated in the whole of the uk
yeah so anecdotally you're hearing
exactly that are you that lots of uh pub
goers uh and clubbers are literally
gonna nip over the border for a night
out
i think we have to be
you know more realistic that there are
many people many people who live in
scotland and live in wales who have
family and friends in england many of
them have already traveled many of them
are staying with those friends and
family and perfectly reasonably to do so
and of course we'll be taking advantage
of
being able to go out without
restrictions
um so yes there will be some people who
will travel but equally there are some
people who as i say who actually live in
wales and in scotland their nearest
towns
in some cases even their nearest pubs i
was down
in
the community that is
on the river y and there are houses in
wales in the same community and their
local pubs in england there's actually
another pub just on the other side of
the river over a bridge that will have
different restrictions
so you know you cannot possibly say to
anyone in that community that they
cannot go to one or other of the pubs
and yet they have entirely different
rules and are both accessible and both a
matter of a few minutes walk
so yes this will happen inevitably and
it shows frankly that we need a little
bit more common sense
and
you know we also have to remember that
republicans have all the way through
this done their very best to keep people
safe to ensure places are ventilated and
actually we would argue that pubs are
safer than people gathering at homes
anyway so we are relaxed about this and
frankly we think ministers should be too
but pubs do need a good new year they
need that because the next month january
is always one of the toughest ones and
it's a tough time for
the hospitality anyway yeah such an
important time of year isn't it
christmas and new year you've written a
letter to the prime minister and the
chancellor what are you calling for
well the reality is that obviously the
the chancellor came forward relatedly it
has to be said with an announcement of
some grants for hospitality
in in england
but those those grants and many pubs
will receive just 2 700 pounds they
hardly cover the loss of a weekend in
many cases the loss
from
a usual night in december and december
has been anything but usual for
hospitality because of vomit common
because of government announcements
so if the if the government are actually
all governments if they're serious about
wanting to keep alive our pop culture to
support our pubs
through this ongoing pandemic and it
very much is still suddenly ongoing and
has to be dealt with then there has to
be further financial support and there
has to be further financial support if
there are any more restrictions in any
of those in any of the four home nations
of the uk and governments have to have
that at the forefront of their decision
and they can do that in various ways
they can do that by cancelling business
rates by having a lower rate of bat for
all pub sales which is not the case it's
only for food
at the moment and so there are various
ways that certainly governments
can support pubs going forward and if
they want them to get through another
difficult winter until we finally get to
the other side of that pandemic then
they need to do so otherwise i'm afraid
that we will see more businesses failing
yeah and nobody nobody wants to see that
of course all right well we listen uh we
wish you the very best for 2022. it's
been a really tough
12 months we raise a glass to you
as we head into next year greg
mulholland thank you very much indeed
nice to meet you
now it's less than six hours until
australia bids farewell to 2021 and
welcomes in the new year and despite
rising covey cases sydney still going
ahead with its annual fireworks display
it was certainly a possibility that the
fireworks might have been cancelled in
fact many revelers in sydney and indeed
in australia are choosing to watch the
fireworks from the comfort of their
homes that's as covert cases rapidly
rise in the past
24 hours in new south wales alone 21
151 new infections have been reported
that's the same amount that was detected
in all of australia yesterday so we are
certainly seeing that rapid spread of
the omicron variant however the number
the number of hospitalizations and also
patients admitted to icu remains
relatively low and quite stable so
authorities are reassured by that also
around 95 percent of australia's
population is fully vaccinated so
authorities are advising residents if
they're going out to take every
precaution to be safe but certainly to
enjoy the new year i'm so i'm here at uh
blues point in sydney one of sydney's
best vantage points as you can see
behind me it typically would be a lot
busier than what we're seeing at the
moment particularly at this time of day
the fireworks are due to start at 9pm
for families and at 12am they will be
the obviously the big show spectacular
but we're not seeing the crowds that we
would be seeing usually in a pre-covert
area era rather the prime minister has
advised that this is life undercovered
however and residents should do their
very best to ring in the new year and
say goodbye to what's been a pretty
crummy 2021
particularly with some of the strict
covert measures that we've seen and also
some of the world's toughest lockdown
restrictions
oh lovely clear blue sky sun shining on
the opera house there in sydney let's
see how it's looking
[Music]
here look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
not as hot as sydney but it's still
incredibly mild for this time of year
with spring-like temperatures but it'll
also be wet and windy at times winter
returns with colder temperatures in the
early days of 2022. well this morning
rain lies across north island along with
central and southern scotland there's a
secondary rain belt sweeping eastwards
across england and wales it'll be a mild
start to the day away from the chilly
north but also windy with gusts up to 55
miles an hour southern parts of the
country will become largely fine with
bright or sunny spells developing
meanwhile rain over central scotland
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
did you know if more of us walked rolled
bikes and scooted to school we would
make a big difference to the air
pollution around our school yeah like us
2021 is going to come to a very mild end
but it will also be windy and unsettled
early rain clearing east will leave a
largely fine day for england and wales
whilst rain over central southern
scotland will ease
further rain spreads northeast from
ireland later giving a rather wet new
year's eve for scotland these wet and
windy conditions will help to keep air
quality high with levels only reaching
one or two on the air pollution index
the air quality report
sponsored by phillips air purifiers
time for a look at this morning's papers
and joining me are the editor of spite
magazine tom slater and the author nikki
hodgson great to see you both again uh i
hope all things are well this new year's
eve uh why don't we start um nikki with
uh the hospitality sector it's a real
issue isn't that i've just been speaking
to greg who is
one of the industry
leaders saying that it's such a
depressing time and they don't really
know where they stand given the
differing restrictions depending on
where you live
yeah well absolutely i mean the
hospitality industry has been absolutely
savaged by covid and i say that as
someone who's married to a hospitality
owner so we really have been through the
ring of these past couple of years with
things
i think what is tricky is that this
this christmas you know everybody was
kind of primped and primed for a really
good festive season and then omicron
just kind of drifted in at the worst
possible moment for the industry and for
the government to decide about whether
to take restrictions or not obviously
boris johnson hasn't done that in
england but in wales and scotland we do
have these restrictions but even so
takings this year have still been 60
down uh on 2019. so you know two bad
years what's really important about this
time of year for the hospitality
industry is that it allows it to build
its cash reserves for the quiet months
of january and february and obviously it
hasn't been able to do that for two
years running so smaller businesses like
pubs like single bars have just got
absolutely no chance at this stage you
know they're not really getting any
financial assistance it's very very
minimal it's certainly not enough to
boost them through what has just been a
terrible 18 months for them and so we're
just going to see even more businesses
probably go bust in the new year which
is not really the way many people want
to start 2022. yeah tom just before we
move on to the front of the times um is
the government doing enough do you think
to help the hospitality sector
well it's difficult isn't it because no
new restrictions have been brought in
and yet even just the mood music coming
from government obviously has a huge
impact on people's willingness to go out
and all the rest of it so he just hopes
more support can be forthcoming because
of the fact that everyone would would
lose out if you know a huge section of
the hospitality industry just didn't
make it through this this last winters
it's a very serious problem yeah yeah
you're right um while staying with a
similar sort of theme front of the times
uh kovid kerbs um there's no need for
any more according to nhs chief
certainly uh looking at the data as it
stands right now it would appear
that maybe the government has done the
right thing by uh by not clamping down
further
well exactly there's actually quite a
lot of good news out there believe it or
not if people are willing to see past
the kind of quite concerning case
numbers
in that a lot of the kind of
fundamentals are so different to where
we were last year it's easy to have that
sense of deja vu and yet as chris hopson
from nhs providers as well as a bunch of
other people who were even experts on
the front line been pointing out to us
recently is that because of the vaccine
defenses because we're not in the
position that we were in last year that
the
the number of cases that we're seeing
and even some of the hospitalization
figures in recent days are not going to
carry on and they're certainly not going
to turn into the kind of tidal wave of
hospitalizations and deaths that we saw
last year you know people are spending a
lot less time in hospital than they did
in previous waves there's also been a
huge rise as chris hopson has pointed
out in what they call kind of incidental
covered infections so a large chunk of
those numbers are people who might have
gone in with a broken leg or because
they fell off their bike but test
positive upon arrival and therefore they
make their way into the figures and
these things aren't disaggregated so
there's really a lot to be positive
about going into this new year actually
obviously we have to be cautious the
virus has surprised us before all the
rest of it but the vaccines really do
work and the fact that we're seeing even
from nhs leaders this conviction that we
don't need more draconian restrictions
on our lives that this is a problem that
can be managed it's something that a lot
of people can take with genuine hope
into the new year i think yeah we all
need that don't we as we head into 2022
just looking at the front of the daily
star
nikki um if we want to keep free of
restrictions then we do need to be able
to test ourselves and make sure that
we're in the clear and we know there is
a big problem with uh testing kits at
the moment and here on the front of the
star they're talking about cowboys
charging 210 pounds for a kit tell us
about this yeah so obviously it's a
jokey headline but there is a serious
point underneath this story which is
that you know people are taking
advantage of the fact you can't get hold
of lateral flow tests they're being sold
online for 210 pounds which is just you
know it's completely moral really isn't
it as well as being extortionate and i
think the even more serious problem down
the line potentially is if we can't get
on top of the supply issue there could
become a genuine problem with the
quality of the tests out there i mean
what's stopping anybody who's a bit of a
charlatan putting together some kind of
proxy test and then selling that for a
price and that would be really really
damaging to our testing situation across
the uk and to the figures that we know
that you know
the figures that we know
are real or not about covert
yeah the picture there of uh of dell boy
trotters testing kits i mean tom do you
think there's an argument to concentrate
fully on the lateral flow test rather
than the pcr test almost scrap the pcr
tests which take a long time to come
back which are hard to get hold of
anyway and we know that lateral flows
are uh perhaps better than we than we
initially thought it telling you whether
or not you've got covid
yeah well it's a tricky one as far as as
you say lateral flows are great
particularly for catching what you're
most infectious um pcr tests obviously a
lot more sensitive so people tend to use
those as almost like a follow-up to a
lateral flow test to confirm but it's
obvious that you know there needs to be
this kind of mix of the two i suppose
and the the issue at the moment is the
fact that because the government has
urged people to be testing themselves
even when they haven't got any symptoms
then naturally the people where they're
most needed it's just it's just been
missing at the moment i mean i think it
is worth remembering though that one of
the things we have done well in this
country is testing you saw recently
queues around the block in america are
people just trying to get a lateral flow
test so whilst these pinches have been
significant and omicron has really set
that up for us this has been one of the
things i think we've done better than we
might like to imagine in some way
um now nikki uh paris u-turn let's expat
britain's return to eu homes
via france this is a welcome move isn't
it but then still banning uh brits from
going directly to france is that right
i don't know actually because i think
this might be tom's story
oh this is tom's story all right tom do
you want to tell us about this
of course no so um this is uh it's been
rumbling on for a couple of days now so
british people who live in the eu will
now be able to return home via france
paris had previously brought in this ban
effectively on expats transiting through
the country by road we saw many of these
kind of viral stories of people trying
to get back to their homes in the
european union but being turned away by
a euro tunnel in particular between
folkestone and calais it seems that
sources in the telegraph story said that
french border police had been told to
interpret the existing guidance in a
pretty draconian fashion we're turning
away a lot of passengers
but this has now been eased thankfully
which will be a huge relief to those
people trying to get back to their homes
and a lot of criticism i think on the
french government given the fact that um
certainly whilst omicron is taking off
in this country you know the rise in
france has been more or less pretty
similar over the course of recent days
so that the utility of this wasn't
entirely clear given the fact that it
would affect so many people and caused
so much distress over the festival yeah
not omicron's so widespread now it does
sort of make make it all seem but
pointless all right let's talk about new
z very quickly nikki uh this story in
the times how are the britain how are
britain's middle class is going to spend
uh their celebrations tonight
well apparently they're all going to be
having dinner parties and that's based
on data from waitrose where they found
that searches for new year's eve recipes
were up 160 percent this year on
waitressoc.com and they were last year i
think really important point though is
that we were locked down last year so if
people were cooking they were only
cooking for their immediate family so
you know is that actually finally a
chance to go out and to have that fun
but apparently really interesting here
most people will be having pavlova for
pudding say uh searches for the recipe
for pavlova are up 1500
wow i love pavlova excellent it's going
to be very warm as well 15 degrees
celsius according to the sun tom and
nicki thank you both very much indeed